happy rainy Thursday he's gonna say the
the weather outside sounds suit I'm just
gonna leave this menu on yeah it's very
nice yeah this is uh just an excellent
like rainy weather app but that's not
just any rain you're hearing that's rain
over the the the darkened city of
Raccoon City well that doesn't work out
at all
I've already been on a stream once today
but we're playing Resident Evil to's
demos yes we are I'm gonna keep pointing
at the camera cuz I don't know what I'm
doing that so we there's a lot people in
the chat saying it's already out you
know we have it a little early because
of Australian time yes so the demo was
up in Australia yeah
which is where this demo came from
mm-hmm and that's why we're playing it
yes the demo is set to come out tomorrow
for everything else but if you'd like to
play early as Tay just put out in the
chat yeah you you just got your Xbox
unloaded off the Australia all you have
to do is go to your system settings and
switch your region to Australia and then
you can just download it yes it's
literally all you have to do you don't
have to make another account or anything
like that
assuming you're on Xbox I think ps4 you
have to make like an account yeah but
anyway we're gonna don't go away and do
that start your download but stick here
we're gonna play it cuz we're gonna
we're gonna take two shots at this demo
jean-luc who's gonna play first I'm
gonna play second we've got 30 minutes
each to make it through the demo and try
to focus green in the office said that
he was able to beat twice yes in 30
minutes so I might take my time a little
bit more with this thanks for keeping it
real hey that's what we're here to do
we're gonna play play video games hang
out have a good time I've also been
playing the original original yes in
anticipation for this game so I'm very
excited to see some of the changes Oh
who's starting your office alright just
starting off skipping ahead explore your
surroundings company how to walk oh boy
here obviously a lot more dialogue man
original no they put the typewriter on
this side of the room that's different
yeah oh yeah it's got like a whole
steric Wow yeah they totally changed the
layout already so I'm gonna do this the
whole stream I'm just gonna be like wow
it's so different so it's also worth
saying that this is both jean-luc and
eyes first time ever playing this game
yeah we haven't played any of the
previous or anything although people it
preview events have been not us we're a
chance to kind of explore inventory
slots only get six so you start off with
the base inventory for either character
that you're playing and then there's a
point where you can you can pick one
like it it's like a grenade launcher or
an extra inventory an inventory
expansion then whatever one you take the
other one is left right right yeah there
we go
is this take place in like 89 like yeah
it's still in the same at the same time
so the the first reveal trailer they
showed like an original playstation to
let you know like I it's the same time
Crimson's wait you didn't play Artie -
no I've played Artie - before I'm
replaying it for the anticipation that
I've played rtq before I love Artie -
they were we've both played Resident
Evil 2 we haven't played this yeah we
haven't we made that the remade yes he's
always break room east office wow that
looks very similar it looks like a very
similar layout I haven't changed it too
much try interacting with the door like
to the outside really quick for me okay
a few map so I can't save I know it's a
one shot demo if they kept the games
like the typewriter stuff it should I
think it's just you can't save because
there's no reason to this saving a 30
minute demo okay so you can go outside
and go outside no loadings in between
that's great oh god it's so rainy out
here what up guys oh they changed this -
it's a little different like the
courtyard area is not really the same
you can't go back down around so we
needed to use it like sprint
I was sick in I'm trying to do like bump
you know I have been playing Monster
Hunter that would do it do the bumper
another fine Capcom game so don't mind
me I'm just gonna kind of take my time
here and look around
yeah we're not trying to go too crazy
okay so they got that's the yeah that's
the same symbol - that's cool
nice little touch we got the fountain
which gets you the keys although they
got three things now instead of one I'm
winning by 10 points it was my idea hey
we're here that we're here to check this
out we're taking our time we're having
fun or find some some cool resident evil
things okay like this how like the
aiming like if you hold if you stand
still it gets more precise yeah
felipe says is it the streamer is the
anti-aliasing generating a lot of
ghosting there's some weird ghosting
stuff I think it's like a stylistic
choice though I don't know if it's
necessarily from my perspective I
noticed it downstairs when you were
turning around
is it 60fps I think it is we're playing
on an Xbox 1x it's worth mentioning yeah
so we're playing on the the higher level
which outputs to 60 I don't know I don't
think the games if it's not a it's
higher than 30 different puzzle okay I'm
excited for all the change the little
changes in the tweaks can I grab this
fern no can I take this fern with me you
know for health how do you download some
one ps4 about digital oxygen can't find
it so we did it on the Xbox because it's
easier to just change your reagent
different I think if you want to do it
on the ps4 you actually have to make up
you have to have an account in those
regions okay so it looks like we can't
go here at all we don't even talk to the
police officer and her that watchman's
remote let's go here though which is
symbol it is a little different actually
they did change him so I'm already doing
this thing we're only in like the first
two areas that we've been
and already I'm like in my head trying
to twist what I see to like be the fixed
camera angle cuz I'm not seeing these
fingers from the same yeah yeah that's
fair
who looks gross I'm just like comparing
like I have a mental map yeah a very
clear mental map of how the original
games police station looks and I'm like
alright how's it different because
that's what I loved about playing the
original remake it's just like all the
little tweaks and changes also this
games way darker oh yeah that original
game is not dark at all okay we gotta
find a fuse for that nope can't go in
there I guess the game does look very
good oh this is the same yeah yeah I
remember that a soda machine oh you hear
that
I hear that yeah why is it so wet it's
all these cold drinks thanks dude we got
I can't read those are de are de
delicious Arta that's that [ __ ] that
just looks like a food food nailed it so
weird name for a drink
the Josh asks what would you like the
next are you roommate to be I want three
so if you like three had the best
concept and not the best executions how
I feel I don't think three holds up very
well but I like three in theory the idea
of being chased by something huge and
menacing us it scared the [ __ ] out of me
when I was a kid it still kind of scares
on me now move this around there's a
there's a chess puzzle and the original
I'm wondering if they also hello there
sir like I may have like left certain
puzzles out to not spoil them or
anything well that's possible but I
didn't really like changed a lot the
puzzles yeah I imagine they would just
want to do that oh when you turn on the
lights he actually put some ways
oh it's an automatic thing okay
microphones yes everything checks out
cool young American flag all 50 stars
- what platform were playing
this is the Xbox 1x hmm yeah we're
playing an icebox 1x oh that's another
good point I wonder how like the
framerate would play on like an original
I'll probably try if I have time left
over when we finish this I probably
won't check it out of mind but I'm still
using my launched Xbox at my desk you
don't get too much in 30 minutes yeah
that's what I'll saundra was saying and
he was able to beat the dinner like
twice so that's why I'm kind of being
real slow here taking your time when you
go the watchman's room oh there's a
bathroom over love you I think the thing
I'm most interested about is so the base
experience the Resident Evil as a series
has always done an amazing job providing
like alternate modes and like on this
version this happens like the like mode
in remake we're like there's an
invisible zombie yeah all the zombies
are invisible there's the one where one
zombie will if you shoot it it explodes
and you just die so you can't hit it
I'm wondering for you that that one's
crazy because you don't pick it it just
happens to you oh that's why it's
flooded pick up that Febreze yep
everything's good yeah spray that over
here it's probably pretty bad probably
needed yeah Oh har that house their mere
tech Oh bad there's no because Leon was
a vampire all along code Roenick axe is
the best and biggest resin evil it's not
my favorite also it's very anxiety
inducing because you can really mess up
a run in it I was saying how it's it's
when Resident Evil got really dumb in in
like its narrative and that's both a
good and bad thing yeah it is the start
of like the first I think I prefer fors
cheesiness over like you know Jesus yes
cook Veronica's cheesiness cuz I think
Code Veronica takes itself a little too
seriously
yeah yes fair mmm okay I like this like
whenever you go up to inspect the door
you like get get a view of it
oh that's guys having a rough today
that's the exit okay just taking my time
dude don't worry about it no rush
all right let's dude I think I know what
happens here
why it's the aim look so off what do you
mean by off feels okay to me I think
maybe because let the reticle looks like
it's maybe not directly where it should
you know like it's not centered or maybe
the reticle is centered but the gun is
like aiming I was like thinking of his
facial expression and then and then to
the gore because have a body's gone okay
they're gonna come at me I'm gonna try
to I've really up the gore yeah officers
know got a statue three medallions the
medallions in the stage go underground
it's like Nathan Drake's notebook yeah
crown heart okay there's some self
Resident Evil ass puzzles and some
puzzle solutions happening cool the
daily raccoon that's a terrible name I
think that's the same
I was looking at the wrong thing you got
me game you got me good I'll admit I
think that's the name of the newspaper
in the old game sewers right that makes
sense
Oh God yeah God
he's missing distinct chunks of my out
of his head I'm fine don't worry fine
I'm fine
darn right Leon is fine they're going
for that like minimal the UI is taking a
lot of clues from for or not for 4th
from 7 yeah yeah that goes up to the UM
the house outside oh hello there could
you imagine what the PC mobs are gonna
be like please video game Oh someone's
gonna mod Oh God yikes
well they were in real nuts on the gore
with this one yeah I didn't like like I
knew it was a thing but it I don't think
I knew how intense it was like until I
see it can I like Barry yeah but you
barricade the windows oh that's cool I
thought it was gonna make me like jump
out like it's scape Leon that man's head
split as the demo out so right now it's
out in Australia the other side of the
world so if you change your region on
your Xbox you can download it off of
that store yes I need to head back to
the main hall yeah
what do you think it down voice it
sounds like I imagine Leon would sound
on his first day on the job rookie cop
think your dad I don't trust them do we
know if they have crimson heads in this
one I don't know so I've intentionally
been not paying attention not paying
attention that's fair I'm part of me I
don't know I go back and forth on the
crimson head thing because that part of
me is like man I want that was great oh
I can tell I'm already gonna get one Ali
on sound board yes that was the most
believable thing I've heard anyone say
in a video game ever I definitely want
oh there you go yeah you could barek you
know college should we go back and do
that yeah let's Burke you try it or
should we say it for another thing let's
do it just to be able to okay see how it
works I was feel more challenging than
the original so far
I heard to say I mean I just started
shot much more original isn't that hard
yeah there's a lot of just running past
things and I think remake is probably
one of the tougher the original games I
think the playing like - I've I've died
I haven't died yet 22 again and I'm like
it's just I I don't think that game is
super tough well yeah his bite marks
healed up okay that's cool that's a neat
mechanic when does the demo release the
demo comes out tomorrow officially yeah
which is why if you look at like the
Australian store it's it's up because
they're they're already in the next day
I'm gonna grab me come on
save me also say you ready for that that
had to get smashed there it is nice
that's that's the line it's safe for now
dang Leon they're putting some real
effort into the acting stuff on this one
yeah I feel like you have to I don't
think you can go back to the like cam
penis at least with the tone they're
trying to go for because the original is
definitely not great dialogue yes though
I'm kind of sad that there wasn't like
an option to have like the original
dialogue for remake for remake
yes don't modded that in someone minded
it but I mean like as a as an included
thing like on here was it Richard it was
like there's a monster in the next room
when this one into this guy he's like
there was an incident involving zombies
in a mansion yeah that's the stuff I'm
kind of there for I would like the
option to do it without modding but I
think I did so much to this that it's
just not possible
yeah this is on the xbox one ex take it
yeah these faces look really good they
do this re engine things just called re
engines pretty good-looking it's the
engine they're using for definitely cry
yeah
you can play re2 with the original yeah
track not the voices you'll see though I
think yeah I think it's part of the
deluxe edition which is why I'm happy I
got it or you could like ah the knife
ready put that away
/ counterbalance the knife retracts
remember the basics of CQC Leon okay so
wait they're just ready there's /
counter-attack okay that's different and
can only be retrieved once you defeat
them it's not like the mechanic of uh
mechanic I'm case if it'll be useful
because it also looks like it has
durability
oh maybe yeah cuz it has like a bar
underneath it dies okay because in the
original game I just immediately put
that in the inventory cuz it's useless
yeah okay so we're gonna go we got to
find the three medallions all right
let's do it
I like how you actually have your
equipment on you so like you can
actually see the knife now on the back
of this belt
let's talking more playing hey man that
is a stream yeah we're here to talk
we're here to hang out take your time
having a good old deal okay so is this
puzzle here oh you know what I have the
answer in this officers notebook okay so
I wonder if those both those pictures
are related well okay there's crown
there's a crown there's a lion there's a
goat
there's a woman there's a harp and
there's a bird and okay there's a crown
there's a sound there's a goat oh damn
there we go one medallion done killing
it okay and then the other one was the
herd woman harp and I think the orders
just top oh no what you can interact
with Anik oh no oh no okay maybe or
maybe it's a different statue and you
have to pick the things that they're
missing because that lion sets you
didn't have the the goat or the I'll
have to go talk to them again say that's
the only eased I mean we solved the
puzzle yeah we did it
did the thing yeah but the passage isn't
open yet
okay also I love Leon's first day on the
job full getup like he's wearing the
elbow pads how artists is given the
highest up called a no idea why you came
change the difficulty on the demo yeah I
don't think we have any difficulty
option auto reload is on that's fine
preparation camera you turn the wobble
off you can invert camera normal game
you change your field of view that's
game play it's like when you're running
around normally okay film noise hood off
that's nice like an I like it
language subtitles re re done night no
uh no difficulty options I would love to
see a alternate like I love um not house
difficulty in seven something like that
yeah it's kind of I was saying before
like just new alternate modes they've
already confirmed that like Hunkin and
tofu are in this game so this used to be
a saver right no this was just the
reception area that had a chest but
they're just any chance wasn't in the
outside like the typewriter was in the
lobby but the chest was in here okay so
know what you're supposed to see when
you come around this corner yeah yeah
yeah let's see if we see it
dang they're messing with us we didn't
see it man see it that's one of my
favorite bits and the remake is the the
hallway where the zombie dogs jump in
and go there the glass just cracks and
you're like oh and then the zombie dogs
don't come on but then they come out on
the way back yeah and like oh that's a
good get alright so they're messing with
people who've played the games yeah I
like that nice
yo you know that guy's gonna wake up
yeah like for sure right boo fancy
really gnarly yeah I think this is the
gnarliest Resident Evil's ever looked
even seven didn't look this gnarly okay
that was before now so it was it was
hidden off the screen you could only see
it if you did like a widescreen
oh no I'm watching my I don't know it
was like it did you know gaming or
something maybe well there's a guy in
the ceiling liquor would show up but I
guess they're not here okay they don't
have like you don't have to go through
any um doors like that doors open now
that's way open I don't like it we
should have saved it from that one can
we get into wait oh shoot sir is the UH
oh hi that made me jump just a little
bit not too much
I open the door yeah let her let her in
should I open it yeah let her in Oh
looks like PT yeah that's okay now I
can't open it oh they're mine she let
herself in okay here's what I want to
know if they did come chasing the room
they can see three rooms so I like that
we want different doors it you have to
open it and then you actually push your
way in I'm going to see if she can come
in Oh weapons Locker key card you know
that man
yeah do it get in here at door come on
they could do that and remake it so cool
yeah
open that door yeah probably have a
second account for streaming we do so
the first 30 minutes is gonna be John
Luke playing then the second 30 minutes
is gonna be me Paul well uh well we'll
have yours be like a more speedy run
we're taking our time with this one
because we want to just look at
everything record of events honestly I
don't even mind if I don't finish this
one by yeah accident because I'm just
kind of taking our time here in fact I
think it's entirely possible I'm going
very slow we'll find out okay we got the
operations room safety deposit that's a
little different but it's really save
room over here in the dark room yeah
it's really easy in this game to kind of
get caught up in just doing the like
slow methodical movement though it's
like I want to go on and not sprinting
it man what if you just shot it out
blocked off Oh interesting
hey hang on a mo when does the dum AGGA
live for everyone say seven minutes left
dang it's live right now in like I just
raelia wait too much to 9 from time but
it's all the animation change it goes
live tomorrow for like us in the US and
stuff so if you want to you could
download it off the Australian
marketplace
hey nice tip I think is good not that
hard
ah this is where the office
my party is yeah it's been cancelled
though your party's cancelled gunpowder
also you have the gunpowder stuff in
this that's from that's from three yeah
you wanna know what I never used in
resident evil 3 gunpowder gunpowder
I never cuz the Gunpowder is random I
never got the gunpowder I needed to make
certain like ammo I just never bothered
nobody trusted that's a good call
I know I've played enough Resident Evil
games I know Oh God we've taken way too
many bullets face is falling apart oh
hey
yikes you can see like gross eyeball
okay seriously why is this dead he's a
strong boy nailed it
is that my sign I think it's your sign
[Music]
Wow brick sound getting here much
earlier then okay yeah I missed the
weapon room we missed the weapon room
think about all the cool weapons we
could get oh I did miss the bucking room
that's fine don't worry about it
we're gonna do I mean that's way more
it's okay that I like five minutes
because we have bends and we'll just
have them rush through is Leon the best
character voice acting for for 2019 so
far cuz I'm way into it absolutely yes
that was such a well delivered line like
it's not even like a oh god I'm scared
it's like I'm fed up with this already
yo man this oh the hallway don't worry
there's um should be a safe room in here
there is we found it oh that's different
this room I believe these lockers are
where you got the other costumes yeah
is my yep it is you know what you know
what really bums me out huh music yeah
I'm not hearing anything there's no
music there's kind of no music so far
yeah I don't know if I'm into that I
don't like that maybe I'll play with
classic just to hear music again cuz I I
constantly bring up how much I love this
way I don't care about the music in the
police station and resonable -
specifically because it has that random
door slam in it
bread herb let's give me some combine
ding that that adds up doesn't mixed
herb I got three minutes
film contains evidence Howard's work on
about how herbs work alright let's just
go through its gonna run it by the
5-minute rush yeah I'm not a fan of the
new music thing I like how it freeze
frames when you window oh there's a
whole nother floor there is no stereo
other staircase in here before huh yeah
that's right
take it nap again oh this is different
yeah yeah more red herbs you bet you can
it's real steamy in here valve oh wow
it's real different I dig this steel boy
something all that steel boy I'm
imagining I would have got a shotgun in
the weapons Locker there's very low
music mr. X has his own theme maybe
there's like not anything when you're
like just moving around and only during
certain parts yeah it's not like risen
table to where it's like every room oh
oh
he crawled up the stage and got back up
again
he's down again down four down oh look
at that that's really good this is a
shoulder to hold the flashlight yeah
that's cool I like that
that's some nice attention to detail Oh
what it's it's a coming off in there
it's a very strong statue it's glued to
the desk steel boy
okay iron man's kid got the key look out
you gotta run it down now time for that
yeah I definitely have time for that
dang that was it there they got it on
the third floor do this floor doesn't
even exist in the original game there
this is on this is the unknown areas an
unknown floor let's get that clock tower
over there I count that got a cool
picture scary doll Oh No thank you
just leave that we don't need that I
hope they remake resident 3 like this
could you imagine a redone resident evil
3 where a nemesis wasn't scripted where
he popped up he would actually die where
that is what I want man it would be too
much I would die I would actually die
probably okay I got how much 50 seconds
what do you do what do you hit when you
just send it out I don't know man okay
killed by that liquor oh there you go
sounds like Flynn all right you'll have
to be a lot speedier I was just gonna
say I would like to see the end of the
poem actually maybe too much of my time
I'm really surprised that I'll saga
actually finish this twice maybe he like
really sped through it I really took my
time yeah I think I think he was one of
people who played the demo to those like
he already
[Music]
okay so we want to go back down what the
cool if you don't like Akuma well the
what's not a thing Alessandro is
mentioning something out of kuma yeah
like maybe that's like a like a rumor
huh or something cuz he was like all
please let Akuma be a thing alright so
we're gonna flip it over to you then
yeah and you're gonna maybe go a little
bit quicker then I try to try to try
don't worry people that's why we did it
twice exactly so this is my OCD is
screaming at me oh for not checking
everything and not do you trust me
same if this was not a demo and I had
more time this is gonna kill me I would
be so methodical I check everything I'm
looking forward to downloading the demo
again so I won't have to like rush
awesome trailer at the end now watch it
with your is I think we actually haven't
uploaded onto the site okay already if
anyone wants to watch it without
worrying about the demo but there's some
really cool things in there I hope that
I'm able to get through this quick
enough so we can actually do it yeah
English so we wanted to would you two
Japanese we could do want to hear that
Japanese Spanish oh but we'll never be
although oh we could will understand
what he says yeah so we'll have
subtitles for good and this is fine do
it good
no take it in letters broke does he say
that no I was talking about that my
girlfriend was she's like oh I get like
like seven it makes sense that they got
rid of it cuz seven was the first I
wasn't able to not do it
mm-hmm Maine resident evil anyway and
she's like yeah like that game's tone is
so like different that it wouldn't make
sense I'm like that's true I also miss
it I like when the games just say than
the name of the game oh the demo the
demo is on everything but it's just
easier it was easier for us to grab it
off of Xbox all right chase I believe in
the I believe in me that believes in you
I'm here I'm here for it I won't grab a
little more ammo at least not
all right fair enough I trust myself
with the one clip I have I'll say that
knife if you get behind him I was able
to take that guy real easily
right oh we don't need to see this yeah
Oh Mike you want to at least hear a
little bit of Japanese oh well here's a
[ __ ] Japanese we will that's what I
read
that's what I'm here for oh I'm excited
for that you've got this I don't even
hear them singing that was weird
hit the Lights
check that body that's got a mo don't
take some of that open inventory cool
it's also getting a ton of ammo yeah you
were you're grabbing a lot do you got
special access or is this general
release this is a general release we
just have it the Australian version
oh he's inside of here no no photos
through the door no no straight ahead
you have to move that oh yeah that
yellow tape that's their their way of
telling you you can interact with it we
on yeah it's so heavy white males really
use the knife after to cut it open
maybe bar on that resonable seven oh
this is just the bathroom on the way
back yes yeah that's this is what I'm
about this is this is good
I'm all for this
I like Leon's Japanese poison yeah this
is great I am definitely gonna play this
game a second time in Japanese it's been
another residency do that I'm not sure
either
[Applause]
it tastes super into it this is lovely
that's ooh I play everything a taste
thing about how he wishes destiny was in
Japanese yeah well it is in Japanese is
that you have you heard Shaq's and
Japanese is so good Japanese Shaq's is
uh here it's incredible
we'll move on here officers no but cool
we got it nice man maybe now that a
bunch is gone
independent with destiny we could get a
Japanese there we go yeah
stay down so you knew about him I did
nice nice nice
yeah you got him imma grab that the
first day of med understand the controls
are like you feel the weight kind of
it's good it feels good yeah I'm into it
I'm diggin it
I like how their hairs like animated too
like yeah I should probably take my time
and like aim but having a stay still
thing is definitely a deal man I wish
you could do things in like I want to
use here a little bit this yeah I wish I
could do a thing like in games where you
could like in Street Fighter where you
can just set certain characters
languages well that'd be really
interesting oh no in my version of
Resident Evil Leon is a Japanese like
transfer police officer yeah he doesn't
he doesn't know English or anything so
he's asking Blizzard relieved Activision
to that's a tougher one because
technically Blizzard Activision when
that when I brought you boy don't want
you anymore technically when that merger
happened blizzards the one who boss
division it was a vendee blizzard bought
activision and became activision
blizzard but they kept the management of
activation so it was like we have the
money to buy you but we want to keep
your management because we think your
management is good at making money which
they are yeah so that's a lot bigger
messy ball that would be maybe harder to
for blizzard untwine unless there's a
way that like the development side of
blizzard could escape it so I don't know
if that would there's a thing that I
really like where they they've got like
random rumbles during cutscenes oh
really it's like when when I grab the
knife and then he grabbed my hand to
like tell me the last thing it rumbled
like that stuff you know does look
pretty good she still got his weird hair
but he's good so I'll go do that puzzle
real quick alright it's gonna go up
stairs
[Music]
so this is I thought work for IGN dude I
see music Vernie you I did at one point
IGN heart so it's crown lion lion and
got it bring it back downstairs I see
mr. makers Canon that's a question like
are they going to because they
definitely I think use the remake
version as canon as the Canon version of
Resident Evil One and it's great because
it actually like incorporates a lot of
the other games stuff later and like
some of the weird mechanical stuff like
in the original Wesker just like dies
but they make a point if I like oh his
body disappeared like what happened to
Wesker like to you know foreshadow like
some of the they they kind of like
integrate some of the cannon into that
game I'm curious if they're gonna do
that for this one a lot as well right
like will you make will this game make
nods through to nemesis for example that
would be kind of cool this is this is
really good like yeah I that's great I
don't know I've been wanting a resonable
to remake for a long time and I'm really
glad that we've got this remake has been
I would say that seven Final Fantasy 7
is probably the most famous like or
infamous like fan-requested remake yeah
but that's never coming out
but resin evil to zwi has actually been
longer people have been wanting a
Resident Evil 2 remake ever since well I
think the brains actually got a remake
for one in the exactly so camp doing
this ever since one got a remake fans
have been asking for a remake up to four
you know at this point sixteen years
right so uh this is this feels like a
really long time coming for like the
hardcore fans you've been wanting this
for a very long time yeah oh look at
that there's environmental storytelling
sighs do you have the did you grab the
thing which thing the board I got time
for boards but they didn't downgrade the
gore nah man if anything they upgraded
it this is by far the glorious looking
Resident Evil I've ever seen very
intense much going here and got that key
card yeah okay so the weapons Locker
where is that weapons Locker events cool
David Ford grab map nice sore any other
hand wanna grab here or anything
I don't think something looks better
when you're playing youtube compression
the video quality oh yeah that's how it
is that skates with all dance
unfortunately see as soon as you head
shot that first zombie and we saw his
like head explode heart it's like whoa
like I understood it cuz resonable seven
better than this well I mean we haven't
played obviously couldn't tell you I'll
say that I love resonable seven I'm
sorry yeah got him so wanted to be sure
you know he can't I can't get in there
so where's people seven is crap Oh hard
disagree on that one
I love reservoir oh this is what I'm
looking for I don't know hold on you
gotta use your locker numbers so what do
we got in these lockers I want something
good nine nine
I see me only get one shot right give me
a shotgun shotgun shells that looks like
it's a the bag oh that's the bag are you
kidding me who are you
nice oh we didn't know that note might
explain spare keys all right can't pick
up all they keep the whole thing we're
like all the weapons yet because the the
whole plot is like the chief
intentionally yeah so let's - oh so to
let everyone die because he's like a
crazy person
so which one you going for us No - are
you trying to go for the extra space
yeah he's gonna try to get it so you
need a fight you probably need to find
the keys to get those what you don't get
until later well that makes sense to
prevent you from getting it ready yeah
so one do you 109 I'm gonna grab that
okay I'm gonna do that so he always gets
something out of here scary it's
understandable
it's fair well that's real Resident Evil
though like the the the thing beeping
and then showing it showing it so can we
do it multiple times they're just the
ones we probably do multiple times I'm
guessing you're gonna be able to come
back and get the other stuff you could
try it with whatever that is
oh that's the film Oh grab it Oh what
was the number I don't look at that
before I walk to 106 106 okay one of the
back of the room all right we'll go to
the back of the room after we grab this
dude wonder if we can I use that film
you should totally develop that film
there that's what we need to keep oh
hello that's what the key cards for yes
please
shotgun oh we're gonna make a mess
get that shotgun steel boys all right so
let's probably grab that other shotgun
ammo - that's 208 but she wasn't on
there where you're right we can't get we
can't get the twos all right let's uh
let's get out of here
well load this up so it's ready very
excited to shoot something with this
the Americans download this now yes if
you are on the Xbox you just switch your
region language to Australian now huh
and if you're on ps4 you just make an
account like a Australian account I'm
not complicated that is though it's kind
of like just hitting up a regular
account but you you can still relate
some eggs to make sure you close the
door I don't know if that's actually a
thing in this we'll find out I guess try
it develop this film the photo wonderful
we've done it that's probably a solution
to a puzzle yeah probably
I'm an keep goner subscribe this let's
grab this I don't need that why did I do
that
help me change out this is the special
key I'm set to I'm curious how they'll
handle that oh yeah it's why Trevor
watching from Island Ireland nice hekia
we are looking good Leanne's always
looking good it's true sounds looking
fine fine boy
yeah you okay over there I heard that
you heard that we all heard that Oh keep
going I guess all right surrender that's
fine I don't think we're gonna need to
heal too much we've already got two
items for ya Oh get off of me
nice we don't know that the games start
from the police station what about
running around wrecking streets no for
reaching there like a listening original
already - this is a demo that they evict
the explicitly say at the beginning of
the demo that it it doesn't play out the
same way as the full game so I think if
a full game you're gonna get proper
intro cutscene you're gonna get the
running around the gun shop they've
shown images yeah I think we've already
seen them yeah they've shown images of
the gun shop and I came running around
like the opening so I'm very positive
that that is in the game I don't think
you need a week they can't have Resident
Evil 2 and not have the kendo gunshot
it's just a demo they're you know they
they make a slice for demo oh my God all
these combinations okay alright that's
the key so we can run back downstairs
really quick yeah sorry shaggy I don't
run there being much there we can we got
that liquor scare again I don't need
that I don't need that let's go back
downstairs and use that key let's go
there the integrate gunpowder though
from three yeah it's three the only one
who really did any other game outside of
three use gunpowder not that I can
remember I just ignored it through I
mean I did take time I saw mechanic that
I just written well again i was saying
how it was like random luck and i just
never got the right gunpowder
yeah cuz if you had like the three types
and you had to like combine them to make
certain gunpowder and i like never got
like see gunpowder or whatever it was
mm-hmm can i play there's multiple times
on it account no well you can
technically play it as many times you
want within 30 minutes on one account
but you only have 30 minutes you gotta
make multiple accounts if you want to
keep playing
like we're playing on the same console
but we were each using each other's
accounts and that's how we've been able
to play yeah I think it's back this way
hmm
now odds around well it is this way no
cuz we hopped over that's right how do
we go back that's a good question you
can use the key um where's the door that
we haven't now all the doors in the
records room
West offsets try the West office oh yeah
you can go back through the West office
less I do it hello I'm here for my party
oh that guy who won't die okay I got him
I'm ready for him you're gonna do it
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay that's fine
dude I'm telling you man it's not gonna
get back up now uh we got that safe we
can't open yet mm-hmm nothing we can
check out over here oh god damn we carry
over to full version no definitely not
considering it's only a small slice and
it doesn't even start at the beginning
operation report I don't think I'd want
it to anyway so I used to do like back
when I did constant twitch streams that
actually play through like the entire
resin evil series and I would read every
note out loud like a complete weirdo
yeah some people are saying they
finished Davone twelve minutes fifteen
minutes cuz this run-through barely saw
anything yes that's why I didn't finish
the demo when I played through because I
was just um you're just checking things
out just looking at stuff I don't need
that you don't need that either
give me a favor after you kill this guy
check how much time ago
12 minutes almost 13 yeah good close the
door on him keep them out oh there we go
now I can open this up to see the key
actually going in nice
what up and back taste is better hurry
come take a look
ah look it's Claire get down get to the
courtyard from the second floor I do it
okay I'm on it
what if Leon were voiced by Kiryu and
nothing gets you but I that was it that
was the end of the demo I was short I
thought I had to game-mode standard I
can't believe oh can you pick an
alternate difficulty oh we can try here
but we'll get to watch that sweet a
trailer here
you did it in 15 so you just I think Lea
got me you want to know that the volume
up for the trailer just just in case
well we can head back in after that okay
trailer play it for me gave it to me I
got so excited like hop and go fine we
can go find Claire oh there we go
oh the last survivor Japanese honk tofu
the real last survivor that's a gross
looking chunk of tofu go to rockfish
purchase this game thing no we can jump
back in them do it again do it on the
hard mode if you can see if there's an
option you seem to imply you could uh
results game store that's or anything in
here brightness tutorials dynamic range
I don't see anything in the options for
it might change this back just for now
though maybe when you start it was an
option what we missed all right let's
check it out story no it's just a
shoe-in maybe that it tells you that
they're gonna have different modes oh
there's no demo a sweet tasty tofu cat I
that was that was what this game looks
really good I want this game now all
right school I guess we'll just use your
remaining 15 minutes it's time to poke
around now looks like pretty much at the
end of the day though yeah you were
right there are these guys oh can you
not kill them that's okay no I was just
gonna see if I could keep going with it
God look at his his face though it's all
gross and missing parts now is there
anything else over this way go down
there
well look at all those body bags gross
yeah man it's the reality of a zombie
apocalypse that's like some Resident
Evil 7 stuff yeah body bags in the
basement the basement body bags
all right let's back back to good old
English Leon head in this one well oh
yeah he's kind of I always thought it
was brown like but just because it
depends on like the MOT like the model
kind of looks more Brown yeah but then
like the in the cinematics are like very
red like orange II okay I kind of want
to get the rest of like the equipment
aren't you people in the gaming news
industry presents you will have adaptive
difficulty well that's cool like it'll
be like a four thing yeah um well for
one we were not asking about adaptive
difficulty we were looking at the
alternate difficulty modes which all
Resident Evil's have had in addition to
adaptive difficulty yeah and also very
intentionally I've been avoiding reading
up anything about this game because I
want to go in as blind as possible and I
don't really work on the news team so
we're not it's not my job to necessarily
keep up on the news and in that sense
my favorite thing to let people know is
not everyone who works at the game site
is a journalist right specifically we
don't work on the news team I make news
recap two video video side but I do I do
tend to pride myself on at least trying
to keep up with news but in the case of
Resident Evil is like hey I want to go
online I missed I missed the thing that
I was supposed to grab no yeah two guys
you got ahead of yourself yeah
all these games coming up this game HD
are uh I would imagine so
but I don't really know it I know that
on the page for the Xbox version it says
its Xbox one enhanced yeah I mean at
this point but I think pretty much every
game that comes out has something
enhancement HDR support at this point it
feels like most most uh big big Triple A
games do Jesus did your timer reset no I
don't believe so no it's just we
finished it so fast that we have time to
go back and play some more it's fine
no no he'll probably have an arranged
mode like theater John but there you
said there's a new difficulty setting oh
okay setting oh get hit by the door well
it's definite gonna have an alternate
mode then considering that that result
screen at the end said what difficulty
we were playing I said the standard mode
so I assumed it would probably have
something ranged mode or like a madhouse
difficulty which I always loved he lost
his hat and I even have to shoot it I'm
too smart for that you can't pretend to
be dead hello
oh I didn't see the the officer zombie
also when their heads explode does that
mean it was a critical hit cuz I know
you can get critical hits I think so
it's like in a that that's not working
older resident evils as well like you
would blow their way my strategy would
be aim up with the shotgun you wouldn't
get real close and then you blow their
heads off what I mean like they're
they're actually like critical hits you
could do with the handgun I think you
can do that in the yeah as the shotgun
was like the reliable way to do it
this wasn't sure if that was like a
thing that they put into this one but I
think that might be what that is and I'm
only shoe only head and they're still
coming he's supposed to be T very
zombies they're taking too long to die
oh man dude out of definitely not true
I've plane a to the other day it would
not go down they took a very long time
frustration it feels pretty on point how
how often I would take for your zombies
to go down in the original they feel
pretty resilient which is conical is
there a RAID mode in this no idea but we
were talking about how that'd be cool
yeah like like mercenaries more than I
like raid modes though you're saying how
raid is like proto mercenaries right oh
no so the raid mode is the one that was
in Revelations which was oh what's the
one that was an original two years thing
just the one with hunk I forget what it
was called
okay last arrived or whatever something
like that yeah I want I want like
mercenaries in it how are the controls
is that that class because there have a
horror feel it's a more action-oriented
I it feels pretty good as far as it
definitely feels like they're trying to
make it have like a weight to it and
then you'll notice like when you aim if
you're moving your aim isn't as accurate
and when you have to like stand and the
crosshair actually slowly zooms in yeah
the the biggest thing is definitely this
like standing still so you need to stay
in proper you want to get like proper
shots so it seems like they're trying to
make a conscious effort to make it feel
that way let's see so on so the key
treats the fov I just want to see it oh
yeah that's actually a good call-out
see I wanted to do before yeah someone
else was asking as well feel that well
let's let's crank it up get it I'll get
that that fisheye effect okay so yeah
it's not even that bad when you turn all
the way up that much but that's a little
bit more yeah what if you go like way
close in bring it in oh yeah it's uh
it's real intimate yeah okay well there
you go there are any other interesting
options we want to quickly check before
hmm
turn Auto reloading on and off control
settings I assume that's just like you
can customize them yeah yeah what's like
a be quick turn and run top you can
toggle run or not dang okay whew whew
control options for ya
camera stuff field view camera wobble
tutorials hug turn I film noise if you
want I'm gonna turn off the HUD to film
noise to see what is the reticle let's
make you the purple sure there's no
purple can't you just make it blue make
that red dot sight blue everything's
blue audio that's fine dynamic range
cool yeah yep alright so got our
subtitles or we got our cutoff we got
our new reticle which we you can't see
because we turn the HUD off that's fine
I'm gonna do it man I'm curious how well
uh you could aim that seems pretty
intense there we've seen that twice now
we ready to see that oh we can actually
knock him down I was trying to do that
before but I was like Nipigon knockdown
yeah oh that was the regular door yeah
right no no that wasn't actually this is
different that was the one that we
couldn't we couldn't get into it because
we had to go all the way back around and
once I say wait for him to come out
Britt hi man you want try and hit him
let her come after me come out like oh
wait you can't see like pickups - oh
that's rough
that's that's kind of interesting Jeff
like use your eyes - yeah
brutal let's tougher because in like the
original game it was very clear like
that's a pre-rendered object that's a
that thing I can pick up yeah this is a
little tougher come on I'm ready for you
Oh God so what's that counter-attack
move oh yeah that's right what was the
input for that hold on is it just just
left bumper by itself well common
caution we'll do one more I'll try to do
it once yeah here we go what's left
bumper yeah and then you lose the knife
though until you you finish them off
oh god that seems real rough and then I
think you can pick it back up yeah so
you pick it up toss your knife does have
durability durability
I wonder if using that move takes out a
pretty big chunk there it probably does
that seems like it would that be the
case
dude I want the scheme real bad same
fight ring I think playing this demo
might have done me a dirty and now that
I just yeah you just want it I'll be
thinking about it a whole bunch until it
was I actually did expand two weeks
until I comes out and only giving us a
oh it's taken a nap
only given us a 30-minute demo as I
understand it but I need more yeah I'm
gonna I'm gonna just use this anyway
we're almost out of time I think yeah we
got three minutes
come on in fighting can you grab Weston
you're right grab that thing can you put
it can you like cover that he comes
through before I I can go back try it
try it out that I'm kind of good oh no
that sucks to be you know there you go
get in theoretically yeah maybe it's
like an eventual thing I mean it'll
break through got all this in here
there's some arrow in there so I didn't
see that uh the zombie that was upstairs
oh yeah that's true at all when I ran
through it we heard him we didn't see
him this guy Nick I was there so maybe
zombies aren't like full set at all
that's exciting
rym zombies yes looks it's great
time's up time to tell you that here a
lot of sounds I'm gonna try to go back
down to that that one door that I don't
think we opens oh hi oh hi okay so you
can't you can't use the knife after
they've already grabbed you it has to be
as they're grabbing you at least that's
what it seems like it's very
uncomfortable position you got the key
re mm-hmm oh she broke the glass can't a
man get through though okay it's a good
way to scare yourself but not have to
deal with any of the consequences it's
through doesn't actually I don't have to
go to talk to him yeah you're right you
want to end it again do you want to sure
let's just let's hear the trailer in
English why not
hello it is I I've returned take a look
we have sounds like such a nerd he's a
rookie he's green he's very cool
collective man we know in for true
anytime Leone oh no could be it twice
you've unlocked the lock the whole game
you've done it so you go game mode
standard that's gotta be like there's
definitely alternate modes find out more
or I can't wait to have a to not listen
to Leon at all again what da hell
there's Claire's guy gotten spicy
Resident Evil Plus tofu hog the last
survivor god I love that okay I'm gonna
get tofu just chilling ah it's so good
it's very good yeah so that is the
Resident Evil 2 demo coming out
officially for I guess people in the US
and everything tomorrow it's up on the
Australian marketplace if you want to
get it yeah I was good I'm very excited
for this video game I'm super stoked for
it I can't wait to dive in it seems like
they've actually made a lot of pretty
significant changes for the way it
operates that it'll feel fresh for
someone who's played the original which
is exactly what I wanted and I'd be
pretty disappointed it was just just
like a carbon copy but with better
graphics
this looks great we'll see tomorrow yeah
well we're doing our community Fridays
as we do just gonna say if if you like
what you saw be sure to follow a channel
we stream every day at 11 a.m. Pacific
usually this is a special occasion where
we got our hands on the demo early
gentle can I do a show every Friday
where we play games with you guys and
tomorrow
we're playing Halo Master Chief
collections come by join up thanks for
hanging out everyone see you guys
tomorrow
good bye